one two three
how are you so good miss you I miss you
too I feel like there's a giant wall
between us I know that you're married to
your husband Daryl and you love him so
much so much so much so much that you
guys have adjacent toilets we do side by
side there's no wall in between us and
in honor of that that's why we're here
love that for all the single people out
there will you play one of my favorite
games Red Flag yellow flag green flag
yes I love this game oh my God I love
this too it doesn't even matter if
you're married or single it's just a fun
way to find out where you're at with
certain behaviors absolutely your date
only talks in the third person
your date calls you dude
well sorry
your date eats their own snack under the
table can you add dinner no your date
pulls out a flosser after eating is this
a stranger or is this like date 30
because if it's my man I'm gonna say
good job babe and if it's a new guy I'm
gonna say you're crazy your date goes to
the bathroom for way
too long that's my man
yeah and you don't mind nothing of the
circumstances your date calls you honey
after the first date
your date eats all the bread rolls in
the basket and leaves it for you
your date touches you under the table
suggestively on a first date
all right no warning no warning because
my love I would be like God I love you
it's a stranger that's a serial killer
your date only talks in Tick-Tock Trends
[Music]
your date takes notes on what you say to
remember it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]